good morning John it's Friday not just
any Friday my darling John it is Friday
eleven eleven what's the big deal about
that I have no idea but sometimes eleven
eleven is a time where you see people
tweet make a wish and I have no idea why
and I could Google it right now but
frankly I can't be bothered but why
can't I be bothered because it's also
the first Friday of president-elect
Trump's president election three
presidential election see I don't know
yes that's right everybody we voted for
Donald Trump to be President I didn't in
particular I don't know how many of you
did but people did some people voted for
Donald Trump to be President moreover
46% of people didn't vote at all for
those that don't know who I am my name
is Hannah Hart I the YouTube channel
called Hart oh I am most well known for
a show called my drunk kitchen
and most beloved for putting my feelings
all over the Internet
but I don't want to talk about me or how
incredible I am I want to talk about the
trouble with wishing because it occurs
to me that wishes are what got us here
it occurs to me that wishing is what
made 46 percent of our population not
vote but let's talk about the good thing
about wishes what a wish is it's your
heart's desires it's it's what you truly
want it's what you truly want to be true
it's what you truly want to see it's
what you truly want to do so in that way
a wish is a great thing because it shows
you things about yourself you might not
otherwise know what's the trouble with
this wonderful thing well it said it
gets you into something called wishful
thinking where you think you can do less
and still get what you want now I don't
want to blame us for what just happened
but I am going to blame us yeah I know
it's not our fault but also maybe it is
so in terms of ourselves and our hopes
and wishes and dreams and trying to turn
those thoughts into actions and those
actions into events of change I think we
probably took that action for ourselves
but what I worried we didn't do is have
enough conversations with other people
beyond our families I'm just gonna say
that it's a beautiful wonderful thing
that we were motivated enough to vote as
Millennials this year that we had such a
strong turnout and I think that the next
step is talking to those members of our
family and the people in our lives who
perhaps hold alternative
Tuukka believes two hours or live in a
world of apathy I am confident that
there is someone in your family that
voted for Donald Trump and/or didn't
vote at all on a positive note I do
think it is an extraordinary thing to
live in a country where we can still act
in accordance with our beliefs and while
we can still do so I think we should
while it is still safe for us to have
these uncomfortable dinner conversations
I would like you to do so if there is a
member of your family that you know has
opposing political beliefs to you I know
it is awkward but show them your Twitter
feed show them the instances of racism
and violence that are already being
incited in quote unquote trumps America
if you have a friend that did not vote
show them this and if they're like well
that wasn't me I didn't vote for Trump
tell them but you didn't vote at all
therefore they are guilty by association
I know you would like to pretend like
your actions don't matter but sorry your
actions and inactions matter a lot so
while we take this time to heal and
mourn and grieve which I implore you to
do so because to rebuild your strength
you really need to rest for a second I
also would like to caution you to stay
away from wishful thinking it turns out
that what we thought was enough isn't
enough so we can't cross our fingers for
next time we can't cross our fingers
that in two years we're going to elect a
congress more in line with our beliefs
we have to start having those
conversations now I'm John I'll see you
on Tuesday or at youtube.com slash our
dub also hope you guys enjoyed this
dramatic lighting it is a dramatic time
which is so exciting one